hello everybody and welcome to part two
of let's play from dust now as you can
see we just got done building my second
village my village my be able to get rid
of this message here and as I do hickey
over here I don't know what it is but my
call people there's a space busting to
call people Oh what are you doing do
something with that it looks it's weird
oh yeah do it Go Go Go man woman girl I
don't know what you are I really don't
do you think what is it oh all right
okay
but not not just yet I want kind of want
to explore around find out what the
dealios is right here let's see what is
it but f oh yeah that's a woman hello
baby
how you doing alright what's this over
here
Oh River Delta deltas as you know where
rivers enter into the ocean but deposit
their nutrients and other sediments that
create rich soil to grow crops on such
famous river deltas are the River Nile
very very rich area end of the Amazon
well also not the same one the different
rivers I know they're different rivers
alright
movin on that's enough geography or
geology lesson today alright nice city
going here oh yeah look at him go
they're really cool I like this I did
not get all right I don't think there's
much else more that I can do drop some
earth let some more vegetation grow
man they they breed quick there was just
like seven of them before Wow
wow that is a lot that is a lot a lot of
people what can I do with them how can i
exploit them water water water water
Oh No there's a tidal wave
sploosh oh that wasn't much at all oh
nothing
come on more MORE I want to ruin these
people's today the people that out I
gave you everything
sploosh oh oh that's not good oh oh no
no I feel bad
oh that's oh no oh no I feel bad down
ahh
what are those get out of here get get
out of here sorry sorry folks sorry I
did that I'm gonna use these tough fend
off whatever these are
splooge get out of here what are you I
don't know but they look bad or maybe
I'm just I'm just used huh I'm just used
to everything being bad in this game oh
I ruined the River Delta F at that come
on I gotta rebuild it I see great a
little channel here the channel for the
water to go through see a little here
did Dan this up so it goes the other way
okay
oh damn it that's the water okay it's
flowing it's flowing still I don't know
what these are
okay let me see if I can get my people
to go over to it nope apparently I can
sorry about the water thing I hope you
don't not believe in me now
Oh what the what in the heck ehekk Oh
what is that what is that what what are
you I don't even know I can't click on
it or interact with it or anything
whatever and they don't seem to be doing
any harm but if I was like that guy I'd
be worried because there are gigantic
big ol monster things right next to it
okay all right I think okay middle mouse
button to rotate camera I think I'm done
here
think so the guy looks older oh okay he
is older oh man this is cool I like this
game I like it a lot
okay all right I'm gonna go ahead or I
can't what the hell
pressing the spacebar and spice button
[Music]
all right never mind let's see what do
have a the objectives menu Oh
oh hey all right cool hundred percent
man I'm the best totem has no power what
does that mean well I'm pressing this
space but oh that maybe that's why I
can't do they can't get to it yeah I'm
gonna get some sand here that's probably
it I hope so
as if not I hate to for this to be like
you know all my other let's plays and I
get lost on the first level easiest game
in the world I can get lost in the first
level just like that
go away water I don't want you know no
water getting sand sandy sand sand all
right that must be done might work
yep oh yeah there we go okay come my
minions to me let us get let us away
from this place and worship me somewhere
else come on hurry up
I haven't got all day old man yes all of
you all of you come on come on oh yeah
hobble faster man oh come on
well why are all the oldest people
coming it's not like oh okay
not like they're even gonna be able to
effectively make a new village because
well well you know you know how it works
birds bees you know babies all that
stuff
all right another little cutscene here
I'm wondering who made these things in
the first place is probably some
backstory on that all right
[Music]
sounds cool
oh yeah the roar of the game ammaji
Massey better guitar in the undie uh-huh
okay
two totems left oh let's populate one
let's get it on my villagers are gonna
get down and dirty
come on come on I like it says call all
the men there are obviously women that's
a woman I think oh no I'm not sure yeah
yeah woman this game is sexist
there are women - women are contributing
members of society and I'm not even
saying that sarcastically oh oh oh I I
did one of those repel water stone
aknowledge okay all right sounds good to
me oh love the graphics look at those
beautiful beautiful all right get some
Earth sandy sandy earth good enough all
right
then posit it in a nice little line for
my peeps to walk across just some
fearful where it doesn't need to be come
on gimme more a little more a little
more
damn that up good okay all right that's
good for there let me get some from here
go give me yo cyano gave me yo sand
there we go okay and then another little
straw back and forth there we go that's
better
all right go get gon get come here yeah
come here you coming
why are you there yeah well that's kite
I like it
sorry to interrupt your kite flying but
there's work to be done a tsunamis
coming two minutes
let's move it oh oh no oh no the bridge
he's gonna get he's gonna die I gotta
save him
Oh Oh save yo ohan such a here ah it's
still her no I got you I got you I got
you
oh I got you you can make it you can
make it a little buddy
you can make it I got the water there we
go that's more like it
y'all right here good thing I took the
water
despite the infinite source of water
over there all right there you go man
good job we get some more Earth
all right okay all right all right that
is now dammed up as best as I can I
think that flow has been diverted I love
the physics in this game you can
actually divert water man why didn't
this game get more attention go go my
little guy go that mask looks like that
of oh man
people are gonna lambaste me for now
remembering but the thing the Mogul from
from final fantasy if you had a big nose
look just like it moguls probably not it
I'm probably wrong don't don't hate me
guys don't hate me please don't hate me
all right let's see what this repel
water can do go man you got 47 seconds
Oh
[Music]
get the lead out oh come on there's not
much Sun I'm imagining it I know I need
a little time to learn what I'm doing
and not let you all die come on man yeah
kiss the stone all right there we go
sounds good to me
so you're permanently water repellent or
something is that what you're trying to
tell me how does that work it's just a
totem that does I'm not sure sure
Oh almost time let's see what's gonna
happen
hello-o oh yeah
mass water physics oh love it come on
bring it on bring it on oh you got
nothing
Oh giant wall of water I'm sure that'd
be terrifying from eye level but I'm Way
up here oh nothing
Oh what oh oh oh yeah you are nothing
Oh get out of here I'll get out of here
I cannot reiterate enough reiterate
enough or say enough how cool those
water physics are that is awesome that
is awesome
just say that's better than some like
physics simulations that take hours to
make very cool very cool or I don't know
I haven't checked up on the latest water
physics simulation software so maybe
it's gotten better
well obviously it has anyway oh that was
cool okay I am going to cut it here
thank you guys so much for watching and
I will see you in part 3 of let's play
from dust
bye bye